this is something that happened to me
yesterday you know i've been stuck at
home because i'm sick i have coveted but
i'm i'm okay uh you have a very you have
the very mild i have the mild i'm
vaccinated so it's it didn't hit me that
hard but my fisher price coving really
yeah
fortunately let me just be responsible
you've been uh fully vaccinated and then
boosted so you uh you got covid uh but
you've prevent presented very mild very
mild symptoms and you've still refused
to really do any work oh but anyway go
ahead okay so anyway me and tak and our
boys we go for a walk every day and
yesterday we're walking and before i say
this you know conan you know about my
temper that i've tried really hard to
you uh you have a hair trigger temper
i've seen it in action yeah when you get
mad you see red and i've asked you to
try and get under control because
sometimes you're with me
and you start to go off on somebody and
i'm like sona i don't want to read about
this tomorrow in the paper yeah that
conan o'brien was seen with the
tasmanian devil yeah
so um
so what happened i'm curious okay so i
it has it's been a long time since my
temper's come out but yesterday
some
[ __ ]
is
jogging with her dog on one of those
waist leashes so she's jogging and both
her hands are free and i'm walking my
dog and we're with the boys and and tax
walking the boys and she's jogging in
the middle of the street on this
cul-de-sac so okie goes towards her dog
her dog comes towards my dog and then
she like swivels because she's jogging
and she goes lady watch your dog
and i go are you [ __ ] serious
and i go they're dogs and i tried to i
actually like held okie back and then
she just kept jogging i was like that's
right keep jogging [ __ ] and i
turned towards tech and i was like what
just happened to me like i was gonna i
will i will tell you exactly because
i have been there for these instances
with you when you completely lose it and
let me explain to people sona's a very
polite kind person
most the time but when you lose it it's
immediate yeah you've got your babies
with you yes you've got you've got these
six-month-old twins with you and you
want to throw down i mean what you're
using is the language of a penitentiary
you want to pull out uh a shiv that you
fashioned in shop
and uh and that you've hidden in dark
recesses of your body and you want to
pull that out and and stab someone to
death in that moment i do and you know
luckily the boys were sleeping and
they're six months old so they won't
remember this but i did i yelled to this
woman keep running [ __ ] like but also
what if that's their first words
what if you're like say mama say dada
and your and your parents are there and
everyone's gathered around and they're
like [ __ ] writing [ __ ]
okay and then charlie says that a
mermaid goes i keep running [ __ ] then
they teach each other how to correct it
and then your sister's like keep running
[ __ ] then they harmonize keep running
[ __ ]
every time you put them down for a nap
and then leave the room you just keep
running [ __ ] yeah
okay
there you go guys nighty night
have a good sleep mama loves you daddy
loves you
everybody loves you and i'll just close
the door and yeah keep running [ __ ] i
don't think you got the stones to be our
mom
it's called a [ __ ] dog mom
i don't need your boobs
we're getting our milk online from each
other what we just ordered some similac
dehydrated milk what the hell off amazon
so keep walking [ __ ] and watch your
goddamn dog
we took a walk the other night and it
was maybe four o'clock and it was just
barely starting to dim and this old
woman jogged past us doing that kind of
walking jog you know and she just
muttered to herself not even to us too
dark to walk a baby
what do you mean who i've never heard of
it's too dark to walk a baby oh my god
what does that even mean i don't know
but i have to say sona i understand it
the problem was i did that thing and
maybe conan you could relate with this
where also we were three houses from our
house and we got in the house and i went
wait why didn't i yell at that lady mind
your own business instead i just went oh
yeah you know yeah well that's that's
you i when things went like that would
happen and my kids were really young i
would i remembered once throwing my
daughter at the person
she was about four months old but she
had some she had strong bones um too
dark to throw a baby yeah i said it it's
too dark to walk a baby but not too dark
to throw a baby
eve ho
well that was that's this grandma
yeah that's good no it's good to have
her straight matt i i would have
exploded and then i would have gone home
and i would have been like why did i do
that but i regretted the other one now
i'm now i'm obsessed with that too dark
to walk a baby yeah
what i've never i don't understand i
don't understand i think everyone's
losing their minds and i will say
i i absolutely love our neighbors but
they saw us walking the baby at the same
time too and then for christmas they got
us two of those like caltrans reflector
vests and it's not that dark but that
was wait a minute i'm sorry i'm on i'm
on their side now i assumed when you
told the story that you when you're
walking a newborn at night that you're
both wearing reflector vests and you
have those lights oh no we were in ninja
suits you were both
you were both dressed as people that put
the scenery out in between yes
at the theater yeah you were wearing
black turtlenecks and and your daughter
has all black on too for no reason she's
a complete ghillie suit sniper
camouflage yeah yeah
right that's terrific and also i've
never been in a fight before i mean i
don't know why i even said that to her
like keep running i mean maybe
kicking in and you felt like no to your
friend she had this before yeah we were
in many years ago sona and i were with a
friend of hers and we were in a very
nice restaurant
on the upper west side of manhattan oh i
know that harvey's and yeah and i got
you know that place there's only one
left sona was being a little loud and
there was a guy way over at the other
end of the table and it was
at the restaurant just on the other side
and he just
kind of made a sh no
hold it he went shh and you went oh
really
really and you stood up and you started
to unload on this guy while i'm there in
front of me and your friend was trying
to restrain you remember
you almost climbed across the table and
tore this guy's face off wow i and you
know who the guy was who stephen hawking
it was
one of the great physicists of all time
stephen hawking and he went shh please
please it's upsetting and she was like
oh really
i've got ideas too about black holes
i'm gonna carve one in your [ __ ]
forehead i wasn't even shushing you that
was the sound of my machine sorry i
wasn't shushing you that was my machine
that helps keep me alive so i can think
of new ways to help humanity in my
shortened lifespan
oh yeah really remember that and then
you tried to wheel him out the door and
security came yeah do you remember any
of this yeah
you attacked him you started hitting him
with a baguette you're right i'm sorry
and then he ended up apologizing to you
i'm sorry if i upset you
remember yeah and then he said wait a
minute i just had her maybe my best idea
yet you went shut it
yeah and then you screamed at him for 10
minutes and then he went i forgot my
idea
who's being a dick
well there you have it the story of the
time
that sona on the upper west side attacks
stephen hawk